welcome to the round three recap from
the Reykjavik open
it's been a very long day of chess
the first game I played today started at
9am it was five hours see the previous
recap video if you wanna
see all my thoughts about that game but
this is round three uh is playing Tim
yoxland from Denmark
older player FM I found a decent number
of his games
and um
actually before the game I wasn't sure
what to expect the first move we can see
he played E4 but I was half expecting
Knight F3
but he played E4 and if you saw the
previous recap you'll know that
uh maybe I I was a little bit
disappointed a little bit tilted
afterwards and I was really really
tempted to go for a staffer game in this
game but I resisted and I played a more
normal uh Sicilian and my opponent
actually surprised me here because I've
seen in the past he's played Knights C3
and Knight F3 but here he played Pawn C3
the alapin Sicilian also known as the C3
Sicilian and this is an opening that
I've encountered over the years and I
actually encountered the same opening
last year against none other than Grand
Master
adibon I was a second round of the 2022
Reykjavik open and aliban actually
played a really nice game I'm pretty
sure the recap is somewhere on my
YouTube channel if I find the link I'll
I'll link it below
but um this scheme actually followed the
same line in the aliban game for a while
uh now I should explain the point of
Pawn D5 and this is one of the main
lines is after takes takes because white
has played Pawn C3 the Knight can't
develop to C3 so this is uh essentially
Justified for black to develop the queen
and it takes time for white to actually
remove the queen from D5 and we follow a
main line D4 and that six and I have
three Pawn E6 and then he plays this
move Knight to A3 which I believe is
kind of the trend these days uh for
alapan players that A3 looks a bit
unusual at first but the idea is to
eventually play Knight P5 and try and
cause some Mayhem on the queen side
so this is still prep I play Knight C6
and then Bishop to E3
um and this is one of two main lines I
think the more common line is Knight B5
right away after which Queen d8 takes
takes takes takes I believe is known to
be uh very close equal and black should
be doing fine here but um Bishop E3 is a
move I encountered last year and last
year I didn't really know the opening so
well and thankfully after I lost to
adiba last year I reviewed the opening
and even though it was a year ago I
still remember the improvement from that
game
so I started with taking and after night
to B5 Queen d8 Knight takes D4 this is a
position I had against adibon and last
year I made the mistake of taking on D4
which just led to a bit more pleasant
position for whites that just got
completely outplayed but this time
around I remembered the move it's not to
take on D4 but rather to pressure the
bishop on E3 and start with a move
Knight to D5
and at first it looks like this move
makes a concession because it allows
white to take on C6 which my opponent
does and after Pawn takes I am left with
these separated pawns but at the same
time I'm hitting the bishop so I have a
bit of initiative and I get some pretty
active piece play after he plays Bishop
D2 I played Queen to B6 and I'll admit I
was out of my crack here like the main
Improvement I remembered was Knight T5
Queen B6 I came up with is kind of a
natural follow-up not only hitting B2
but also preparing Bishop C5 to create
the the battery and actually when I
played Queen B6 I was calculating a
funny mating idea if white plays C4 here
attempting to remove the knights I would
play Bishop C5 and say oh no my knight
someone call an ambulance
but not for me because Bishop A6 would
be checkmates so I thought this was a
cool mating pattern light would of
course have to play a move like Queen E2
and then yeah then the queen and Bishop
are kind of in each other's way so
um I would be happy there
so my opponent took a think and we can
see from the time stamps like we both
played the opening pretty quickly but
after about seven minutes my opponent
played Queen to B3 uh simply offering
the queen trade and instead of taking
right away which would actually improve
white structure and open the a file I
play the move which provoked white to
take on B6 uh move Bishop C5 hitting F2
and after it takes I take with pawn and
I was happy to fix the structure uh have
the a file have my pawns reunited and
yeah from here it's a more positional
queenless middle game it's not the same
sort of tactical slugfest that we saw in
my previous game but I was happy to just
get a a more quiet game where there's
less fireworks and um it was a position
that was actually very pleasant to play
now there's a few things I do want to
note during the game I was really tired
and I made them a terrible mistake of
not having any tea or coffee and I was
jawning so much and I felt bad I was
trying to hide it and sitting next to me
maybe I'll share a picture
um there's a picture on Twitter
sitting on my left was Simon Williams
sitting on my right with Dina balancaya
and they were both streaming and the
cameras were capturing all directions
so I hope that I didn't defend the
online viewers but the good thing was it
was very sunny like that we were next to
a big window and the Sun was shining I
think the the sunlight helped reduce the
melatonin in my system
so anyway back to the game
um Bishop E2 I play Pawn F6 uh violating
the Ben Feingold rule but I figured Pawn
F6 was actually a nice move because I
want to play Pawn E5 at the same time
I'm restricting the knights and I want
to just have a happy place for this
bishop and one thing I'll say I don't
want to give like too much away about
what's gonna happen but starting with
Pawn F6
pretty much every single move I make
for the rest of the game until it gets
tactical is a simple improving move so
if we just watch
blacks moves
every single move improves the position
or the setup in some way uh White
Castles I expand the center of course I
had to save my Bishop
white was also attempting to improve so
I complete development Pawn A4 King S7
connecting my Rooks trying to get my uh
h8 Rook into play Rook B1 Rook d8
on G3 and uh yeah from here my pieces
look relatively optimized and now it's a
matter of trying to figure out a plan
now G3 was a useful move from White
because he's preventing Knight F4 which
was an idea when I played Rook d8 I had
actually intentions of playing Knight F4
and Knight D3 combined with Bishop F5
really hammering away at this weak
Square in White's territory but after
upon G3 I decided to play Pawn C5 which
is an interesting way to make progress
trying to activate the bishop and after
the trail on C5 my Bishop finds a happy
place on the diagonal and if we look at
White's pieces they're relatively
restricted especially compared to my
pieces which are a bit more active and
centralized uh like the Knight is
completely restricted by my Pawn
structure this bishop doesn't have a
great Square because pawns the pawn
chain just takes away most of the
squares E3 is off limits so I was
feeling pretty good just with uh the
square control in the position and after
Bishop T1 it was a very sad Square for
the white bishop and I just keep
improving I gain space on the king Side
Pawn G5 ideas of Pawn G4 questioning the
purpose of the knight uh he starts with
Rook C1 I Advance Knight D2 and I'm Pawn
F5 so preventing Knight E4 and
um yeah I had ideas of like playing Pawn
F4 I was also fantasizing about lines
where I played H5 H4 take Rook h8 Knight
F4 Saka Knight Bishop D5 and the
Checkmate on each one even though Queens
are off the board it still seemed like a
fun position to attack on the king side
so here my oppon played Bishop to B5 and
I played Pawn H5 so continuing with this
Pawn storm idea and then Knight C4 was
played hitting the pawn on E5 now I
didn't want to Advance upon because this
would allow the Knight to kind of come
in and be annoying a little bit so
instead I defend with the King and in
this position my opponent took a few
minutes to think and I was anticipating
a really cool tactical idea now my
opponent didn't play the move I was
hoping he would play but I do want to
show it because there's a really unusual
and really kind of beautiful
aesthetic tactic that you don't see
every day I was anticipating Bishop to
D2 which looks like a normal move at
first maybe ideas of Bishop to E3 to try
and get some trades but after Bishop D2
there's a really really nice move for
black and I'll give this as a tactical
quiz for the viewers if you want to
pause the video and find a cool tactic
for black feel free to do so but the
move is combining a lot of different
tactics in one is Knight to C7 the this
is a double discovery unleashing not
only the bishop but also the rook and
it's combining multiple ideas of
removing the guard I'm threatening to
remove the guard
of the night The Bishop's defending the
night so I want to take the bishop and
win a piece but I also want to take the
knights and win the bishop on D2 and
when I saw this I was just kind of
getting uh jittery because I was hoping
this would happen uh just such a a weird
retreating move with the Knights but
white has no defense here as far as I
can see but instead my opponent played a
move which I wasn't anticipating Pawn to
A5 and I thought for a little bit and
very quickly I realized
I have the same tactical idea even
though the Bishop's not in D2 as a
Target I still have this resource Knight
C7 and now that the bishop is undefended
White's position is just crumbling
because the bishop it's tied down to
defending the knights and it can't
really stay defending the knights if
Rook B1 I would take take and take
so at this point uh White is in big
trouble my opponent used most of his
remaining time I think thought for yeah
we see the clock went from 14 minutes
all the way down to under a minute
eventually played Bishop T6 but uh my
opponent was just realizing that his
position is lost and I went ahead and
grabbed the knights after takes I took
with a knight on eight I figured it's
nice to keep the Rook on the file and if
takes I can always take and redevelop
the Knights he played Pawn Asics
and I play Pawn B5 just solidifying the
bishop on C4 and the two minor pieces
are just so much more powerful than the
rook in this position so we played a few
more moves uh Rook D1 Bishop D3 Bishop
D2 and here I was trying to figure out
the most precise way to convert and I
decided to play a tricky move now at
first it looks like there is a tactic
Bishop E2 or Bishop C2 but this would
actually be a blunder due to Bishop G5
and I'm losing my Rook on d8
so I decided to start with a nice move
Pawn to F4 simply obstructing the
potential for Bishop to G5 and after he
took then I play Bishop E2 and after
takes I don't take back with King
because it still allows Bishop F4 check
but rather play King E6 the darks for
Bishop can't check my king on the light
square and then he played Rook B1 I took
the bishop and he resigned yeah that was
round three it was um probably my
quickest game of the tournament
and I think overall it was a pretty
smooth game and I was satisfied to have
won this game without too much trouble
especially like after the opening I got
exactly what I wanted just a kind of
easy queenless middle game uh made a lot
of improving moves so this is sometimes
a nice strategy to just gradually
improve keep applying pressure
not forcing matters but just being
patient and waiting for the Tactical
opportunity work nicely in this game so
this puts me at two out of three now I'm
recording this uh very late at night
it's still March 30th it's 11 50 p.m
March 31st is 10 minutes away in Iceland
so I should probably get some sleep
and um yeah I might be a little bit
behind with upload schedule but at least
at the time of this recording I will be
playing round four in about 14 hours 15
hours from now pairings are actually up
so I should probably prepare I'm playing
uh Gregory markson from the USA he's 70
something years old so should be
interesting so stay tuned for the next
one and now it's time to sleep